Shrieka? Where are you, baby?
You know, they say it's the
last free place in America.
And it is, for people that
live here year round.
People got places they can
stay, and they're safe.
We do have name streets, we do have
neighborhoods, like a normal city.
But we're not paying land rent.
We could never pay land rent here.
What do I need a city for?
Can just live out here, for free.
If Palm Springs and Deadwood, South
Dakota would have an illegitimate child -
it would be Slab City.
And that's Deadwood, South
Dakota of 1876, not today.
Shrieka?
Oh, Shrieka?
Where are you, baby?
Shrieka!
Dammit dog, where are you?
My name is Robert Lane.
I came down here two and a half
years ago to visit my best friend.
And he wanted to trade
his place for my truck.
After thinking about it for
a day, I decided to stay.
So he took my truck
and I got a home.
I always start off with
my home town news,
even though I haven't been
there in nearly 3 years.
It's nice to be able to know what's
going on in other parts of the world.
To know that people are the same everywhere.
They all have the same worries and concerns that we do.
Color of our skin
doesn't mean shit.
You fuck around with children, or threaten
children, you're gonna see my dark side.
I even trained my dogs to protect
the children around here.
Last week somebody had every last
possession they owned stolen or burnt.
It's what's known
as Slab justice.
He was...
He was a real asshole.
He went to jail two weeks ago
for threatening somebody,
and within 24 hours of
him being in jail -
all of his stuff was stolen
and burned to the ground.
Nobody called the police when
the fire was immediately set.
They waited 'til it was inextinguishable
before calling the fire department.
That's how hated
this person was.
So... There are morals out
here, they're just different.
A lot of people have put a lot of taboo about it.
But it's just like any other neighborhood,
any other city, any of that you'd find
here in the US, as far as I know.
Where is that bag?
- What bag?
- Our shit.
It's the same thing to me, man.
If somebody took my fuckin' travel bag,
I'm gonna beat the shit out of 'em.
Where's my bag?
If there's a fuckin' Black Widow there,
don't be puttin' your goddamn hand down there.
No, Black Widow's right there.
- Have you seen my green duffel bag?
- It's right here, Bro.
You just get the wrong
impression, you know.
I mean, if I looked at somebody like this,
that looked like me, I don't think I would trust him.
But I'm the most trustworthy
person you'll ever find.
You give me a thousand dollars
to hold for ya for six months,
when you come back, you
might get 999 dollars back.
I might have spent a dollar on some
bubble gum that I can't chew.
Fuckin' buried.
The wind stopped blowin'.
Life is good out here.
Some hippies do shave.
Not very many, but some.
I own a place called the
Slab City Internet Cafe.
The only public place in town for internet,
electricity and, in the mornings, coffee.
The coffee situation...
It's interesting, he
don't even like coffee.
I can't stand the crap. It's the
nastiest tasting stuff I've ever tried.
And I tried it twice
just to make sure.
He has never drank coffee,
he's gonna live longer than us.
I can't even stand
the smell of it.
The smell turns my stomach.
But my customers like coffee, so I
give them coffee in the morning.
He taught me how to
make it his way.
Can you carry this one out?
Holy shit.
Holy fuckballs!
Fuck shopping malls!
So great. Java loves us!
So good!
My day usually
starts pretty early.
The wintertime, I'll start
coffee about 6 o'clock in the morning
to get coffee out for
the customers by 7.
I wouldn't know if I make
good coffee or bad,
but I've been told I make
the best cup in the county.
Gobbles a lot of coffee in your mouth
before you even try to take a sip.
I do coffee from 7 'til 10 or 7 'til 11,
depending on how many people are around.
I'm open 7 days a week.
I don't have coffee all day long,
because they could drink me dry.
Oh! I wasn't blocking!
I run strictly solar but
I have enough power
coming off my panels that I
can provide electricity -
up until maybe 2 hours
before sundown.
I have no power, no
lights, no nothing.
This place - you can take your cell
phone, you can plug it into a power cord,
you can charge it up, you can
do that with your computer too.
And if you've got people you
wanna keep in touch with,
you can get online, which
seems to be pretty unique.
I think he's got 6 or 8 batteries over
there and a 1000 watts of solar power -
so the people can come
in there and plug in.
All he is asking is for donations so
he can pay for some of that stuff.
Rob's one of my best friends.
The cafe has always been
like a home for me.
A home away from home.
It's probably one of my
favorite places to hang out.
Pretty fuckin' awesome.
It's a community, it's
like a small neighborhood.
Everybody out here is pretty much like
family. Not everybody, but most of us.
Damn, it's already 11 o'clock.
God, this morning's gone quick!
Hey Charlie!
Come here, baby.
Shrieka!
Oh, Shrieka...
Damn that dog.
Shrieka!
Come on!
It took a little while to get used to the
heat, but it definitely beats the cold.
Less than 300 people live
here during the summer.
Wintertime, there could be
as many as 2000 people here.
But come June and
the real heat -
they're all gone.
You're talking just...
Just the people who can
tolerate extreme heats.
Which is a very hard thing to do for a
lot of people, that come out without -
the knowledge or understanding
of this desert.
Because it does get very
very hot in the summer.
125 degrees, 130 degrees.
We're talking 50-55 degrees Celsius,
for people who can't convert.
When it gets up to 125 degrees...
I hardly ever drink during the summer,
because the alcohol dehydrates you.
So I do all my drinking
when it's cool.
Get my belly ready
for the summer.
- I'm not going anywhere ever.
- No, in your mind?
Oh, in my mind? Oh no, in my
brain, I'm here, waiting on a bus.
I'm here, waiting on a couple
of buses and the president.
But that's never gonna happen.
But that's OK... Sit around,
waiting, patiently.
I randomly found my
way to Slab City.
I was on my way to my
friend's court case in LA -
and we ran into a friend that
mentioned Slab City,
so we made the way here,
we rented a BMW -
and that car blew up, we traded
it for a van, that blew up...
And we finally
made our way here.
I was travelling through when people were talking
about this free place to live in the winter.
We came out here to check it out.
I fell in love with the place.
I was like a snowbird, I would come
down every winter over to Arizona.
While I was camped there,
two ladies came up and said,
"George, you ever been to Slab
City?" "No, I've heard of it..."
"But I've never been there."
"Oh, God, you gotta go there, you'd fit right
in, you'd fit right in to Slab City life."
Snowbird is a type of person
who runs away from the cold -
kind of like I did.
But they only come
down for the winter,
and then as soon as the weather
starts to warm up -
they'll go back north to
where they came from.
I decided to change
my life around.
Be wild, and...
Do the things they told me I couldn't do
when I was teenager and all that other stuff -
rebel against society
and everything.
Got myself in legal troubles that
sent me to prison for 7 years.
And, in the last year, I've
just gotten out of prison.
There is no hostility.
I don't think there's a single person
here that hates another person at all.
It's been amazing.
It's been a long time since I felt
this accepted in a random environment.
Now, I'm starting over my life
as a single, elderly lady.
Payed my debt to the society and
got out and came down here.
I hadn't intended on
staying permanently...
There is a lot of quiet
moments, which is nice...
I spent a lot of time in a big
city, I enjoy the big city,
but I also like the peace
and quiet of the country.
Just coming here has
really changed me -
in multiple ways:
mentally, physically...
Before I got here I was, honestly,
just hurting other people and myself.
And now I've come to the realization
of who I am and what I'm worth...
I have Slab City and the
people here to thank for that.
Come here!
Now.
There are no public
utilities out here, so...
If you need water, you have
to obtain it for yourself.
You don't pay rent but you still pay.
You gotta pay for water.
You gotta pay for your food.
You gotta pay for your
clothing and the laundry.
The upkeep on your dog.
The upkeep on your place.
You gotta pay for that and you gotta find
a way to do it out here the best you can.
One tank is between 270 and 300 gallons
of water. That usually lasts 3-4 weeks.
- George?
One of the great things about my place
is that I'm the only one out here -
that's got a shower that's
got a hot water tank on it.
Everybody stops by and
I gotta help 'em.
It's not really a public shower. You do
gotta come over and ask permission, but -
George is a nice enough guy that
most people, he will say "yes" to.
People come by and I charge
'em 3 dollars for a shower.
'Cause I've gotta burn my propane.
And then the water...
I gotta run in and
haul my water, so...
3 bucks is pretty cheap.
You have to be very conservative
with your water out here.
If you take a shower, you
take a trickle shower.
You wet yourself down, turn the water off,
soap yourself up, turn the water back on -
rince yourself off.
You flip a light switch and it turns
the pump on. And you take your shower.
If you could do a shower
in less than 5 gallons -
that just means you've got
shower water for another day.
Don't use it during my TV time!
It's pretty cool.
You look so much better!
I bet you smell better too.
I feel pretty... Oh, so pretty.
Yeah, well, you don't
look any better!
I give him showers for free.
That's how good of a friend it is.
Like it costs 3 dollars
to be my friend.
A good day for me is a slight breeze
outside with a nice sunshine
so I can go outside and
do my normal activities.
I live out here in Slab
City because it's awesome.
I've three older brothers
and one sister. 4 dogs.
I work out here every Saturday, picking
up garbage off the side of the road.
There is no more jobs
out here to do -
except being a gas station
worker or food market worker.
During the week I go to school and
basically do nothing except school stuff.
Then I just go home
and do my homework.
Well, supposedly do my homework.
And... That's about it.
I am still hoping to be able
to go to the moon one day.
I'm serious. I've been
wanting to go to the moon
since Neil Armstrong touched
down on the moon in 1969.
I may not be able to
travel to another star, but...
In 5-10 years I could
very well stand on the moon.
And I would love that!
I wanna be like a soldier in
the US Army or Air Force...
Somewhere around there,
when I grow up.
Because, I wanna just
hear gun battles -
and see what it's really like
instead of video games and movies.
On the other side of the fence, off
of Canal Road here in Slab City -
we have 3 military bases.
We've got the Marines, the
Air Force and the Naval.
And everyone once in a while you
get the airplanes going over,
you get the bombs going off,
you get the firing...
Test sites is what it is.
It makes it quite loud if
you're not used to it,
but you get used to it when
you're out here long enough.
Once in a while you'll see a cloud of smoke
rise up off of the top of the mountain -
and then like 10 seconds later,
you'll hear this... BOOM!
The cloud of smoke will already be there,
you're just hearing it afterwards.
It's like... Delayed.
I like seeing the helicopters
fly over our heads...
What they mainly do in the morning is go
really really low and really really loud.
They're not supposed
to wave at us.
About a month ago, there
was three of 'em -
they were flying
real' low over here.
And I stood out here with
a beer, waving at 'em.
And somebody hung out the
door and waved back.
I don't know if they got
in trouble for it or not,
but that was the
first time in 2.5 years -
anybody had ever waved back.
Yeah, made me feel pretty good.
They saw me.
You know how you send around
notes in classes and shit...
We're passing around notes
and Miss Reed comes around:
"Listen, Mr Fields.
What are you doin' passin' around notes
while I'm trying to teach a class?"
- I'm like: "Well... I'm bored."
- Bored as fuck.
And she was like: "You can leave this
classroom right now and get suspended" -
"or you could stay in this
classroom and go to detention."
I'm like: "Miss Reed, you're my
favorite teacher, I love science."
"But if you give me
detention, I'm not goin'."
I'd say I'm kind of a greeter
but I'm kind of family too.
A bunch of the kids like to talk
to me and hang around with me.
I'm saying kids like half my age.
20-year-olds.
They adopt me as "Mom".
I was thinking to myself:
why do I have detention?
I haven't done anything wrong!
So you know what I did?
I stopped doin' all of my work.
I didn't do fuckin' shit.
I went to the class and
I put my head down.
They won't say it out
loud or anything else,
but there is a couple of 'em
that look at me like Mom.
I kind of fit into that role.
I've had five kids. My youngest
is 21, my oldest is 30.
I got four grandkids.
Haven't seen any of 'em.
So it finally came to the point
where I met the principal.
So I'm sitting here like this, sleeping on
my desk, and this motherfucker comes in -
takes that big-ass fuckin'
textbook off the table...
Fuckin'... He didn't hit
the table, he hit me!
I jumped off that chair and fuckin' knocked
him one right in his fuckin' mouth!
Well, Zack is my brother.
Personally, that dude is funny.
I like waking up and Zack is right
there and knowin' that I got a brother
that's with me right now.
Bitches!
My brother was killed
by the law enforcement,
and my cousin was killed
because of gangs.
I miss them.
So much.
I miss 'em.
I was flippin' the fuck out.
I'm not allowed on any public
school grounds in California.
Ever.
EVER.
Zack is my guy.
He is cool, man. He helped me
out when I first came here.
He was like: "You! I like you!" And
I'm like: "I like you too, Bro."
We've been cool ever since.
Did you take my cigarette?
Yup.
Man, I can have
nothing around here.
You know Casey and Timmie?
My older brother taught 'em that it was cool to
run up to me as fast and as hard as they could -
powerslide, and punch
me in the balls.
I can't have any more kids
besides the one I have,
and I don't feel anything if you
punch me in the testicles.
So, good luck!
You don't feel pain in your testicles,
I don't feel pain in this foot.
'Cause I've been kicked in it so many times, 'cause
everybody keep thinkin' that's my weak spot.
No, buddy! It's actually
my strong spot.
All through my life people thought
that because I walk like this,
that foot is my weakness.
At one time, it used to be.
But so many people have tried to kick me in
there... Actually have kicked me in there -
that I felt pain when
it first started.
But I'm just so used to gettin' kicked
there. Doesn't mind it no more.
And I'm gonna do to you what I would do
to anybody else that throws a kick at me,
I'm gonna grab your foot...
- You think you're invincible?
- I'm not invincible, but I'm gonna grab that foot...
- That's what you're thinkin'.
- So let's go out there and test the theory -
or it can get dropped right now.
- You wanna go test that theory?
- Yes.
I won't put you to sleep,
but you will tap.
I love music.
Actually, I am a beat creator.
I have been making beats
since I was young.
Started gettin' good, everybody recognized it, it was
like: "You're doin' good, man, you should keep goin'!"
Okay. Kept goin'.
You can hear one of
my instrumentals.
It has a piano solo...
And the beat drops.
Tap!
Tap! Tap!
Tap! Tap! Tap!
Not again!
Middle school... I got tired of gettin'
bullied, so I'm like, okay, I'm a cripple.
Okay, so I'm gonna get
my fighting skills better.
Joined wrestling.
I had to wrestle.
You win some, you loose some.
But you live to fight another day.
Never give up, Nigger!
That my friend, is a
professional wrestling match.
I smile a lot because I try to hide
all the pain that's inside of me.
That's all I do, every day.
We do have a moral code. As warped as it may
seem at times, there is a moral code out here.
It may be a little
anarchical out here...
Everybody lives by
their own rules.
As long as it doesn't interfere with
me or affect my life negatively,
adults can do as they please.
As skewed as it may seem to the rest of the
world, we have a very strong moral fibre.
Your neighbor waking you up at 3 o'clock
in the morning when you're sound asleep?
- Then go live in a residential community
where there's a fuckin' bed-time...
Oh, I don't give a fuck for tweakers
anymore than I give a FUCK for alcoholics!
- I banned that shit from my cafe!
- I'm not condoning the bad behaviour of people -
but I'm saying you can't categorize
someone by the substance they do.
You know what? Yes, I can.
Because if they know they have a
problem, they have the power to stop it!
I respect Rob.
He's tryin' to do well over there.
He started gettin' tired of the tweakers -
so he started runnin' them out.
And everybody liked him for that.
You know they stay up all night -
yellin' and screamin'.
And he was gettin' tired of it.
We have a big problem with
meth addicts out here.
Americans call them tweakers, because
they like to tweak with things.
Stealing things from other people...
They're very desperate drug addicts.
The police can't do much about that.
And they're not much worried about it either.
It's very hard to get the
police to respond out here.
You can't make rules in a
place where there's no rules.
So you've got the fucking right to wake
me up at 3 in the morning? FUCK YOU!
You even have a sign in
front of the internet cafe:
"WE REMEMBER FREEDOM".
Freedom is not the right
to fuck your neighbors!
A lot of people didn't like
what they saw here personally,
and refused to see
the whole picture -
and they go away thinking that Slab City
is nothing but a bunch of drug addicts.
And it's not that. It's
an artists community.
There are unfortunately a lot of
alcoholics and drug users here.
That's the type of place it is
when you don't have to pay rent.
You're keepin' us all up over here because you've
got all these fuckin' tweakers over here -
they're always up
all fuckin' night.
Well, guess what? You're
gonna fuckin' leave -
if you don't like it, shit's
gonna start happenin'.
Come on, Rob.
I'll be there in a minute.
There may sometimes be a lot of yelling
and screaming, but you know what?
It's better to yell and scream and get it
out than to hold it in and let it build up.
And... Let it come to the point
where you harm somebody.
And I understand what you're saying, Rob,
and I apologize, I get it and I agree -
but how can you take
someone's side,
and let them come in when it's
not his fuckin' situation -
and he's done more damage to the
Slabs than anybody fucking here?
Zack has had, just like a lot of people
here, has had a very fucked up life.
I have a chance, given time, to show
Zack that there are better ways...
He could have walked up behind that
guy and put him in the fucking grave.
He didn't.
The Zack that I met 2.5 years
ago would have just fucking
taken a club and beaten'
the guy over the head.
Dude, I'll beat the shit out of you
with both of these coffee thermoses
and then pour 'em on you.
I can't say nothin' bad about him.
All the people will be like -
"Oh, he is this, he is that..."
I've been with Zack ever
since I've been here,
and I haven't seen him
do nothin' wrong,
unless it's for a reason.
You have to respect people out here, or
they're not gonna respect you at all.
Hey! Look at these douchebags!
- Hey look, it's a couple of fucks.
- Look at the tapeworms!
This is an alpha community.
Everybody up here is an alpha.
And, of course, when two alphas come together,
they're eventually gonna butt heads -
if they don't have their space.
But, we do for the most
part live in harmony.
Rob doesn't like
violence at the cafe.
We don't induce
We try to stop it
as much as we can.
In the cafe, the only thing I allow is pot.
Anything harder and they get tossed out.
I don't even allow
alcohol anymore.
If they wanna get drunk they
can go somewhere fuckin' else.
I try not to be negative,
as much as I can.
When negativity happens, when
there's fights and stuff like that,
I try to forget those.
I remember 'em, but I try
not to harbor on them...
And I try to look at
the chirping of birds.
The beauty of the desert.
I try to remember something
beautiful in that situation,
and that's what
I try to live my life by.
Sorry Rob.
I accept your apology.
None of what you did
was intentional.
Well, Rob, I gotta tell you...
He's one of the wisest
men I've met, actually.
The way he brings himself and the way
he... Like, if somebody gets an argument -
the way he diffuses it and
the way he words things...
He loves to conversate with people,
he loves learning about people.
He just loves people.
Rob's a great person.
- Hey Steve?
- Yeah?
I'm just peeking in to see
if Shrieka is in here.
Yes, she came in.
- Shrieka did come in?
- Yeah.
Shrieka? Are you in here, baby?
No, she's not in here.
Shrieka!
A lot of us have got our dogs
and we get attached to 'em.
The cafe's got their own dogs.
They were puppies that were born
together at the same litter.
If we didn't have all the dogs, then there
would be a lot of problems around here.
'Cause whenever I get angry,
all I do is pick up my puppy -
and look at her face and
all my anger leaves.
Gentle.
You teach her gentle.
You teach her gentle, Kato.
We protect children,
we protect animals.
We treat our animals better
than we treat ourselves.
Me and my dog, we usually spend all
day here with nobody comin' around.
I enjoy the solitude of just being
alone and being able to relax.
Yeah, I love it out here.
I just love it.
If I had one wish, I wish I
could find me a nice woman.
I even posted it
online, on Facebook:
"I'm looking for a nice
woman, to stay with me -
do the cookin' and cleanin' -
do my laundry..."
And everybody said:
"You want a maid -
you don't want a fuckin' wife!"
Tomorrow's my birthday.
I'm gonna be 65 years old.
It'd be nice to settle down a little bit.
And it'd be nice to stay with a woman.
Share that with, you know.
And now I'm gettin' all
sentimental and shit.
Shrieka?
You get to know the animals,
you get to know them by name.
They'll run out, they'll talk to you,
they'll say hi to you in the mornings -
and then they go on to
their journey of the day.
There you are, baby!
Hi! Come here!
Come on!
You had me worried, baby.
Come on up!
Hi Gator.
Yes, hi Gator.
You had me worried, baby.
Well then, I gotta avoid the
police until April 30th.
Is it traffic tickets?
It's traffic court, it's not a ticket,
Bro, it's a fuckin' evading arrest...
- You was evading arrest?
- I destroyed a cop car with a F-350.
Hey! Fuck off!
You're gonna come play next to me right
when I'm drinking coffee, piss off! Go!
GO!
Go, motherfucker!
And that's how I got caught up and that's why
I'm going through all this stupid bullshit now.
Today is my brother Zack's
birthday and he is turning 19 -
and we're goin' to celebrate
it by doin' everything
under the sun that can
not get us in trouble...
While still having fun
at the same time.
I at least have to not go to
jail until after my birthday.
I will eventually,
one day, be leaving.
There will come a day when I won't
be able to go up on the roof anymore,
to move the panels around.
- Hey Zack? You wanna come here?
- Yo?
Yeah, come here. I need you
to fix this a little bit.
We've got this back and we can't
have the cord, and also...
And when that day comes, that will
definitely be the day that I leave.
Who knows? It may be sooner
but, right now, this is home.
And we're goin' to get
so hammered tonight.
I don't know what we're doin', but
we're gonna have fun tonight.
We are at The Range,
a very special place...
I advise everybody to come to
The Range at Slab City. Please.
Saturdays, like tonight, is one
of the biggest nights of the week,
because we all gather up on the stage
that was set up by Builder Bill -
and it's called The Range.
That's when the alcohol flows through and I
do have my good times on Saturday nights.
Sundays are my day off.
I don't do nothin'. Somebody comes over, wants
somethin' done, I'll tell them I'll do it on Monday,
because I've usually
got a hangover.
It's fantastic, I just go out there
and dance, dance my heart out.
And I'm better when I come back on Sunday.
A whole better person again.
Yeah, we work hard and we
play hard out here too.
Different tones, different
pitches, different instruments.
I've seen all the way from a cello to a
flute to harmonica playing the blues -
up there on that Range.
It is a range of music.
I may go down to listen
to a new musician
for half an hour to an hour,
but that's pretty much it.
This place keeps me pretty busy
and by the time that's goin' on,
I'm pretty tired and just
wanna sit back and relax.
Dream on!
Thanks.
I'm as human as everybody else,
I make my stupid mistakes.
But I do tend to be
self-reflective.
Think about...
Geez, what did I just do?
What I wanna really do?
Don't stop learning,
don't stop growing...
Work harder each day to be a better
person than you were yesterday.
And never rest on your laurels.
For your own personal growth,
you need to constantly learn.
That's the mistake too many people make,
is resting on their accomplishments.
You gotta keep doing
something new.
My mother worked for the
same employer for 32 years.
My sister is months away from putting in
her 30th year with a single employer.
Couldn't do it!
Maybe if I was an
astronaut for NASA, yes.
I plan on going to the
moon before I die.
They keep kicking me off the private
network and it's really pissing me off.
So before you leave we definitely
have to take care of the internet -
and me getting on and
off without complications.
Yeah.